imagine the following dressed as a woman
I solemnly declare I promise that I will
do my best to be true to myself and
develop my beliefs to serve the Queen
and my community to help other people
and to keep the guide law as a guide
leader now I've adapted the guiding code
to make myself leader and now despite
only self identifying as a female I'm
good to go to take a bunch of girls aged
7 and above on trips where I'll help
supervise their sleeping showering and
toilet routines unbelievable isn't it
and when it became a major safeguarding
concern for two leaders they were
expelled by Girl Guiding and it's
possible their packs will close down
this group think that means all trans
rights Trump just about everything else
is plain wrong I'm all for support and
for understanding but these leaders are
misguided in every sense of the word I
[Music]
was curious about how you're gonna deal
with this topic because I know it
requires extreme sensitivity so this is
a really difficult it is because you're
balancing rights on both sides and on
the one hand I and safety I'm very
concerned about the rights of trans
people who have experienced huge
discrimination and I think this whole
conversation about making it easier for
them to be recognized in the gender
they're transitioning into is that in
the past the experience of wanting to
transition was very invasive and quite
all kinds of unreasonable things on the
other hand I'm also highly conscious of
the concerns of women worried about
anyone who chooses to self-identify with
no checks and balances kind of walking
into women's only spaces yeah
and the government's consulting on this
at the moment and there have been a few
things happening for example these
outside ponds in Hampstead Heath what
goes to me said that anyone who
self-identified as the woman could go
into the women's pool and then they
change their minds because it meant that
some women weren't comfortable swimming
there anymore so I think it's a really
difficult issue I think you've slightly
simplified what's going on with guiding
because it's not just about guide
leaders it's about the children as well
it's about safeguarding it it's about
safeguarding Safeguarding Children is
non-negotiable it's the most important
thing so if two women have do it yeah
right if they have saved up respect
they probably know more than your either
I agree but I think if you look at what
Girl Guiding are saying they've said
they are saying that they didn't dismiss
these women who raised concerns because
they raised concerns but because they
were doing things on social media that
were imitating others that they went
public you know that that they hadn't
conducted it in lineman there before I
bring others in and I know this is
sometimes it's cheap and Zumba but I'll
bring fill-in X but you have a daughter
I do it would you be happy with your
daughter going off on some kind of Girl
Guiding trip should you become a Girl
Guide with a bloke who self-identify I
would want to know that Girl Guiding
have done proper safeguarding putting a
group of girls with a man who somebody
who is physically a man without doing
proper safeguarding would be a huge
concern so I would what I would want to
know and that's why I think this is a
conversation I don't think we have all
the answers but I'm very suspicious of
anyone who says this categorically is
the situation a trans person can never
work with girls in a guiding context or
a trans child who was born a boy can
never be part of Girl Guides I think
that we need to be open to fact that
this is a this is the front line of a
huge change in society and we don't have
the answers but we need to be very
sensitive Phil's chomping at the bit
this is it is mr. confused right mr.
confused on this one it's a very
complicated [ __ ] but there's a few
things that are brought out this one is
you know the safety and safeguarding of
the kids has to be paramount has to be
at the forefront of every argument in
the Trump's it Trump's any gender like
the safety of our kids anytime maybe
we're dealing with them with a minority
fringe type of person who it's always a
minority got the loudest voices by the
way isn't it I mean it they shouting and
screaming the these transport I'm gonna
say trans people because I don't really
understand it fully myself properly but
what I will say in regards to the two
girls that lost their jobs okay is that
they are in an organization which runs
itself on discipline and if they found
themselves falling outside of that
discipline then they had a job on anyway
didn't they they had to move on if they
feel there's a safeguarding concern is
it not their duty to make they flagged
it up I think it was more a case it
wasn't for the safeguarding concern it
was from the way they conducted
themselves especially in your own your
own game if your supplier of rifles that
don't fire properly isn't the duty of a
soldier to say hey buddies raise
something we'll get done about it of
course it's not your duty but I'm not
going up against policy what even though
they're giving you
don't fire it's this this isn't the case
we're talking okay I think sometimes
employees have a dude if they're worried
about the safety I said something they
have said some the way I've understood
this is they haven't fallen though
they've had to move on for going against
the grain in that respect just because
do you mind Majid just because we've
been talking about what go guys just
very quickly just to explain very
quickly what the goal guiding policy is
because they say if an adult self
identifies as women then there are able
to undertake all adult roles young trans
members should be able to share
accommodation with other young members
if they wish members are entitled to use
the facilities of the gender that they
self-identify as and it's not a
requirement or best practice to tell
parents that a trans person will be
attending a residential event very
important again imagine because you've
got a statement so the Girl Guides have
issued a statement and they've said
keeping girls young women and our adult
volunteers safe is our number one
priority we're really proud of our
robust safeguarding procedures which
apply to everyone and underpin
everything volunteers and girls do in
guiding we are deeply saddened that
anyone would suggest that we would
knowingly put our young members at risk
as an organization we pride ourselves on
caring for every individual simply being
transgender does not make someone more
of a safeguarding risks that risk than
any other person we do serve others moji
I I think that first of all it's really
important that we recognize that the
debate does seem to get shut down very
quickly I'll give you one example of
that on the women's side women women who
are concerned and yes it's very
sensitive there was a poster that went
up and the poster simply stated the
dictionary definition of being a woman
it said woman women noun adult human
female and there it is right there and
what happened is that a personal twitter
complaint it was a doctor whose
non-trans he complained and the company
that put that up prime site prime site
apologized almost instantly within hours
and they said that they promised through
remove that poster because they didn't
mean to offend and so the debate has
become too overly concerned with causing
people offence and shutting down that
the natural concerns are some people may
have and all I'd say is that actually
looking at this policy the gold guide
guidelines have stated that when a
person is 18 or over it is unlawful to
tell other people that they are trans
unless that trans person has given you
permission to do so which makes sense on
the face of it what I would say though
is if a parent is sending their female
child to a girls-only Girl Guides and
not knowing that there is a male to
female trans person responsible for
supervising their say showering and
their staying in tents I'd say that that
parent if they then subsequently find
out that they would have a natural
concern to say hang on we didn't know
that was the case and because it's
saying it's illegal to actually for
understandable reasons out somebody how
is the parent mentor knowing you're
taking their choices away as well that's
why this debate has to happen Rachel I
want to bring you in after we hear from
the one Phil you mention her this is the
former guide leader Helen Watts who in a
way as the the whistle blower let's see
what she said despite no change in the
law membership of Girl Guiding is now
based on the principle of self-identity
boys who identify as girls are treated
as any other girl when it comes to
Residential's the trans girl who still
has the physical body of a boy and who
the other girls may have known as a boy
until recently is entitled to use the
same sleeping changing and washing
spaces as the other girls if they choose
and the other girls are not given a
choice I just need to clarify that Helen
Watson the other guy AG leader is saying
that they they were expelled you two
blowing their cover or talking about
safeguarding concerns as regards social
media campaigns or whatever else that is
unclear so just move on from that and
that is unknown well your guide or
brownie no wasn't but I mean I think we
have to ask whether Girl Guiding is
going to be allowed to call itself Girl
I mean after you're not allowed to put
up a poster saying the definition
technical dictionary definition of what
a woman is how do we define girl as it
now applies in Girl Guiding it's not
girls it's just anyone who thinks about
it's very complex very sad you steer a
path through this Rach well what I think
that the principle I would apply is you
have I don't like these sort of
absolutist positions that is
situations are taking saying you know
you cannot tell the children my daughter
let's say on a camping trip in the back
and beacons and she is not told that
actually the the person who is looking
after her is a trans woman is physically
a man now I'm prepared to accept that
children are much more across this whole
trans movement as than we are we
oldsters but I still think it's quite
confusing for children as well as for
oldies like me and Phil and I think it's
wrong that you can't say to children I
think they're much more understanding
than maybe we are by the way Miss Jones
used to be Gareth Jones but now she's
Miss Jones and it's all fine and then I
think everyone can understand it what I
don't understand me this as well as if
you go back to that statement on readout
from the Girl Guiding they say that
simply being transgender does not make
someone more of a safeguarding risk than
any other person that's true but the
same sentence could be said about boys
and men simply being male doesn't make
you more at risk of being a problem sir
for safeguarding if you were to apply
that logic because what's good for the
goose is good for the gander and these
people have still won one imagines if
they're self-identifying they still have
biological male organs and so what I'm
asking and what I'm wondering is if that
is the case then what's the purpose of
separate sex organisations in the first
place you're gonna take that line you
might as well merge them which of course
leads to other concerns that other
people's intensity I just want to tell
you what Stonewall says because that's
the charity for and LGBTQI people who've
got strong position on this and they say
no child should face discrimination or
bullying simply because of who they are
refusing to include trans young people
can have serious consequences for their
safety and well-being and is also
breaking the law it's really important
that active steps are taken to include
to create inclusive environments for all
lesbian gay bi and trans people I think
in this debate we're focusing on the
adult leaders and I totally understand
that and this is a story about an adult
leader who has left the guys and it's
very unhappy about situation but this is
also about the children and that creates
a real dilemma because if you've got
Girl Guides you've got trans girls who
want to be part of that leaving them out
and saying they don't care
as girls is really really problematic
but then obviously them sharing spaces
and washing to the teasing you know from
both sides they might be very
self-conscious about their bodies being
it's from the other girls so it's really
difficult but I think we should I just
want to say I think it's we've got to
think about these girls are very
vulnerable trans girls trans children
are extremely vulnerable discrimination
being spewed they later have mental
health problems they have high risk of
suicide yeah it's very important to
think how can we get organizations
seriously I figure the way I would leave
this whole conversation is so long as
the safety of the kids is paramount and
foremost everybody's thing then included
exclude as many people as you like but
just make sure those kids are safe as
what I'm saying coming up after the
break
so I've come into the city to speak to a
fella who deals with veterans on a daily
basis in fact he employs loads of them